Queen Elizabeth just released a
statement saying the whole nation has
been shocked by the death and injury in
Manchester last night of so many people
adults and children who had just been
enjoying a concert Britain's Prime
Minister Theresa May said this morning
quote this attack stands out for it's
appalling sickening cowardice 22 people
were killed in the bombing 59 others
were wounded as thousands of young
people left mariana grande concert at
the Manchester arena the lone bomber
died in the blast
investigators say they know his identity
police announced this morning that
they've arrested a 23 year old man in
connection to the attack he was in South
Manchester CBS News senior national
security analyst Fran Townsend is here
she was homeland security advisor to
President George W Bush Fran good
morning good morning we heard the prime
minister say they believe they may know
the identity of the suspect this
additional arrest this morning what else
is at the top of the list for them so
right now they're looking at anything
they know about this man his home
address is work address any associates
they'll look for computers and cell
phones they'll look for social media
accounts anything that can explain to
them this man's Network to know for
certain as Theresa May suggested whether
he acted alone or with others should
social media companies play a role here
Oh charlie so you know just hours before
in the telegram channel the social media
encrypted communication site there is an
Isis channel that said kill them where
you can right it was a video encouraging
attacks and then right after the attack
they as you know there are hashtags pray
for Manchester Manchester bombing Isis
took the over those hashtags to
disseminate their propaganda and so look
social media sites have to do more
before these attacks to take down that
propaganda not just after them but
friend when you look at this just this
just seems to be a different kind of
cool when you look at the audience that
was targeted is there anything that can
really be done realistically I think
parents everywhere can relate to this I
could have gone to that concert they're
saying I would have taken my kids and
left anything you can really do
realistically to stop this you know Gail
look we do that we do security screening
beforehand and there
conflicting reports about how good that
screening was going in but of course
most of that security is gone when
people exit the disturbing thing about
this there were many exits he
deliberately chose that exit which was
the one closest to public transportation
in order to get the big largest number
of people and so yeah I expect now
you'll see some effort to do screening
as people exit you can have an explosive
sniffing dogs and that the like but you
know wherever we put screening they're
gonna they're gonna more ability that's
right if this was Isis or al-qaeda or
some other terrorist organization are
they trying to send a message that we're
still here and we can still get at you
absolutely Charlie look we don't know it
was this a homegrown person from the UK
or was this a refugee or some sort of
foreign fighter coming back but that's
right no matter how decimated they are
in the so-called Caliphate they're still
in places around the world that pose a
threat to us and obviously to our
children you see comparisons to but a
clone I do you know bodycon the staad de
France there where there was a sports
stadium where an individual tried to get
in I think you know we always see these
warnings about large public gatherings
and this is wide what they're looking
for is the largest number of casualties
then can what do we know about the
bombing you know look they're looking
now about the type of explosive that not
release that that will be key charlie to
understanding whether or not this is a
terrorist all right Fran Townsend always
good to have you here thank you so much
and in full disclosure we should mention
that Fran is under active consideration
to be the new FBI director she has been
interviewed by the Trump administration
so we wanted to note that as well